[Applaudissements]
donc il pénètre chez vous et
donc
vous situez la deuxième fois que vous
faisiez la deuxième fois tout à fait en
une semaine non non
à peu près d'accord un mois deux fois la
première fois ils sont rentrés chez vous
ils ont en fait la première fois 20
heures je venais de fermer les volets et
puis
j'ai des caméras de vidéos surveillance
qui détecte la présence et à ce
moment-là en fait j'ai été prévenu qu'il
y avait une personne chez moi le temps
que j'ouvre que je que je descende que
je réalise ce qui se passe il était déjà
en train de partir ils ont volé des
choses non c'est pour ça que j'ai pensé
il était seul il était seul on pense
qu'il était il était seul sur les faits
mais il était il y avait des complices
plus loin parce que impossible de
remettre la main dessus
alors
on a vu vous allez sortir une arme
légale vous allez voir la vidéo dans un
instant quelle est cette arme s'il
s'agit d'une arme de défense c'est ça
ouais en fait je vais déjà préciser
avant c'est que ce qui s'est passé c'est
que j'ai vu ça et le premier cambriolage
en fait j'ai pas réalisé tout de suite
je me suis dit mais en fait
il est resté 40 secondes il a rien piqué
donc c'est qui va revenir c'est un
repérage et j'ai eu peur pour ma famille
parce que j'ai deux enfants en bas âge
je suis restaurateur moto
genre je restaure des motos qui sont
introuvables dans le monde et
quand une valeur inestimable et
introuvable mais on a l'impression que
là il passe limite par hasard on a
l'impression qu'il voit il voit que
c'est ouvert il repasse il contrôle le
voisinage mais ce qui me au début je
pensais que c'était un opportuniste mais
la personne elle est exactement où il
fallait aller tout de suite
là j'étais malheureusement en train de
faire ce que tout homme est en train de
faire habituellement quand il a envie de
faire pipi et
ouais il s'est passé vous étiez où vous
là là je venais d'ouvrir mon portail
pour aller mettre du carburant parce que
j'avais une compétition de moto le
week-end qui est arrivé et je me suis
dit c'était la fameuse pénurie d'essence
c'était un une aventure et je partais
pour une aventure pour trouver du 98 et
je me suis dit je peux pas partir en
ayant envie de une envie pressante
pareil je pense que vous savez ce que
c'est l'envie pressante ça nous est
arrivé vous me connaissez bien Adrien
merci cette séquence m'a plu ça me fait
plaisir ça arrive à tout homme donc là
vous étiez en train de faire pipi donc
exactement et ben j'ai tout lâché ah oui
mais véritablement et j'ai tout lâché
comme vous et c'est parti et je me suis
dit non je peux pas y aller c'est pour
ça que je suis pieds nus c'est pour ça
que j'ai la salle on va voir on va voir
la vidéo regardez
[Applaudissements]
incroyable cette vidéo folle c'est quoi
cette arme là que vous avez c'est une
arme de défense légale qu'on a le droit
de posséder à partir de 18 ans et sans
casier judiciaire c'est quoi c'est
flash-ball c'est une sorte de flasher
je précise que j'ai acheté cette arme là
parce que d'une part j'avais peur et
deuxième part il y a un de mes collègues
à moi qui s'était fait cambrioler une
semaine avant où il s'est fait carrément
attraper avec des coups de bar à mine
etc et j'étais pas à l'aise et quand ça
on le voit sur la vidéo je suis pas à
l'aise je suis tendance j'ai jamais eu
aussi peur de ma vie je
[Musique]
pour moi c'est pas normal de devoir
mettre en joues quelqu'un pour se
protéger ça avait fait le temps que la
police arrive mais j'ai une chance
extraordinaire c'est quand j'ai appelé
le 17 il m'ont dit vous avez de la
chance pardon c'est qu'il y avait une
brigade à moins d'un kilomètre de chez
moi c'est pour ça qu'ils sont arrivés
aussi vite c'est on va voir la police
arrive
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
qu'est-ce qui vous ont dit la policiers
étaient énormément content de d'attraper
un voleur sur le fait accompli ce qui
arrive très très rarement
je les avais prévenu au téléphone que
j'avais une arme de défense je pense que
le message n'a pas été passé parce que
15 minutes après ça j'ai eu la brigade
d'intervention qui a débarqué chez moi
et après ils ont exposé derrière donc
déjà merci à eux d'être d'avoir
intervenu aussi rapidement mais non mais
tout de suite il a dit je cherchais du
travail tu cherches pas du travail en
piquant un groupe électrogène quoi mais
sincèrement il est ça a duré 15 secondes
il est il est il a été interpellé
interpellé tout de suite il en est où là
il en est où là il doit être en vacances
on m'a brave simplement dit qu'il avait
quatre
identités différentes d'accord 4 agies
différents quatre nationalités
différentes il était en mesure
d'expulsion sur les quatre sur les
cartes d'identité voilà ce qu'on m'a dit
et on m'a simplement dit aussi que bah
ils étaient obligés de le relâcher et
que il serait présenté devant le
tribunal s'il avait envie de venir au
mois de mars et on m'a dit simplement
aussi que il y avait 90% de chance que
il viendrait pas encore
envie de ce qu'on m'a simplement dit
c'est que ils savent pas où ils habitent
ces personnes là
qui sont pas solvables donc c'est une
perte de temps il préfère s'orienter sur
des personnes là donc là
il dit quoi donc là il était relâché il
va recommencer donc là peut-être
avoir les beaux téléphones qu'il avait
dans la poche je pense que il y a pas de
problème aujourd'hui vous avez peur que
qu'il y en a d'autres qui reviennent ou
qui reviennent je pense qu'il a dû dire
assez copains que il fallait pas venir
chez moi il essaiera peut-être une
maison un peu plus loin mais c'est
désolant d'en arriver là en fait c'est
sincèrement en toute honnêteté j'ai
jamais au trembler autant de ma vie que
en tenant on joue aucun cas même si
c'est une arme de défense même
c'est pas normal c'est 500 non pas
normal d'en arriver là quoi d'avoir peur
d'être chez soi quoi
Gilles vous dites NON bon vous comprenez
pas non je comprends pas c'est à dire
que je respecte j'aurais fait quoi alors
il doit faire quoi il appelle la police
il appelle la police mais sans arme on
peut pas pointer comme ça quelqu'un
c'est pas possible et ensuite une arme
comme ça moi je donne mon point de vue
non mais attention
une semaine avant il s'est passé la même
chose si la personne s'est échappé on
l'a pas retrouvé c'est compliqué alors
mais en fait en fait ça sert à rien ce
qui est en vrai ça sert à rien on a eu
de la chance c'est que la première fois
la personne n'avait pas de gants avait
je pense qu'on a peut-être les images il
a la lampe de poche dans la bouche
pareil il vérifie contrôle et on a
réussi sur les communes a ouvert le
portail avec les mains on a pris les
relevés d'ADN les empreintes et là on
m'a dit simplement bah il faut attendre
8 mois un an pour avoir les résultats
d'ADN et d'empreinte soyez patient dans
tous les cas d'ici là il sera peut-être
même plus en France il sera peut-être en
Espagne ou autre et là j'avais vraiment
envie en fait j'avais envie d'arrêter
quelqu'un et pour une fois faire une
bonne action en me disant bah ça sert à
quelque chose
en fait ça sert à rien d'avoir une arme
je l'aurais laissé partir l'action
finale c'est la même c'est strictement
rien passé exactement c'est ici et en
fait par recul tu dis mais tu prends des
risques c'est ça pour te protéger mais
au final non je parle pas de risque
qu'il était il avait peur de venir vers
moi il était à 3 mètres 4 mètres j'étais
à 4 mètres de lui mais c'est pas normal
de d'être obligé de sortir une arme pour
se défendre mais bon moi je pense qu'il
avait raison il avait raison parce que
c'est pas pareil que si tu dis j'ai vu
quelqu'un dans la rue et de faire de la
justice toi-même dans la rue moi j'ai un
raisonnement comme ça la justice dans la
rue je ne la fais pas Gilles dans la rue
la justice mais quand tu rentres chez
moi amuse-toi à rentrer chez moi comme
il a fait lui pendant que je sors et il
est chez lui le bras il est chez lui
c'est lui qui est dehors c'est lui qui
en dehors de sa maison tu me fais un
truc comme ça moi je suis comme lui je
le braque après vous aviez bien fait les
policiers ou pas juste pour savoir
réellement ouais ils étaient sincèrement
content d'attraper un voleur sur le fait
accompli ils sont dit enfin quand il
était relâché
la gendarmerie le peu de gendarme que je
connais le peu de policiers que je
connaisse ils ont même plus envie
d'aller travailler ils prennent des
risques ils prennent des risques
inconsidérés pour sur la route pour
aller attraper des voleurs pour protéger
la population il y a rien qui suit
derrière il y a mon avis Bruno Pommard
qui me dit il a des problèmes Verdez pas
comprendre ça c'est vrai que voilà alors
c'est la réaction de Bruno pas de
problème voilà non mais il aimerait bien
savoir qu'est-ce qu'il a qu'est-ce qu'il
aurait fait on peut pas braquer une arme
si quelqu'un
on appelle on appelle la police
mais on braque pas une arme le mec va
pas t'attendre et ensuite il y en a
beaucoup qui pense comme
pardon vous appelez police alors on va
attendre ensemble
[Rires]
deux minutes frérot parce que je prends
deux trois trucs importants moi je me
barre je te laisse la maison moi j'ai
juste
dingue là où il y a des flingues partout
aux États-Unis vous croyez qu'il y a pas
des cambriolages il y a pas des viols il
y a pas des agressions ou pas la société
on parle de ce de cette de là là
en général on parle de cette situation
là il est dans cette situation
moi je comprends votre effroi j'ai
absolument pas vous accablé parce que
c'est extrêmement choquant mais malgré
tout le problème c'est pas ce que vous
avez fait le problème c'est le vide
juridique c'est le fait qu'il y a un
gars qui de deux jours après ressort et
ton liberté on sait pas comment il
s'appelle on sait pas qui il est on sait
pas d'où il vient en fait nationalité
différente il a quatre qtf oui mais en
fait il fasse rien les lois sont pas
appliquées il est pas mis dehors et et
il y a une impression et un laxisme
en fait j'aimerais avoir le oui Castaldi
là la question c'est qu'est-ce que tu
aurais fait si tu vois quelqu'un
donc tu ne fais rien tu fais quoi
donc là dans ce cas précis il y a c'est
la deuxième fois il a une arme de
défense qui est d'ailleurs légal il met
en joue le mec quasiment inoffensive
quel est le tuer honnêtement ce monsieur
monsieur
qui l'a victime si qu'est-ce qui se
passe attends
il va vers ce monsieur dis-donc
qu'est-ce que tu veux et il lui fait du
mal qu'est-ce que
Benjamin
le problème
non mais il a des raisons de tirer il
tire bah encore une fois c'est un câble
pas monsieur mais plutôt sur le sur le
fait que vous soyez terrifié parce qu'il
vous arrive monsieur mais Benjamin la
conclusion de ce qui s'est passé là
c'est on prend une arme et Raymond si on
prend une arme et si le gars est
menaçant on tire vous êtes malade c'est
la France
le problème il aurait même pas dû se
passer parce qu'il est pas censé être
sur le territoire exactement alors je
vous le dis il est sous le coup d'une
obligation de quitter le territoire
français il est déjà connu par les
services de police et c'est vrai que
voilà sur la première fois on essayait
de le cambrioler c'était et donc un
moment
il fait quoi alors lui il est pas
hors-la-loi puisqu'il n'a même pas été
vous avez même pas été poursuivi non
mais non mais j'ai le droit de l'avoir
mais je pense que si vous entendez un
cambrioleur chez vous en toute honnêteté
je pense que vous prendrez la première
chose qui a battent de baseball
un club de golf un couteau c'est pas la
même chose Monsieur que vous preniez
pardon une batte de baseball
entre guillemets dans votre malheur et
dans votre vous le dites vous-même vous
avez tremblez vous avez eu de la chance
entre guillemets que ce type là soit pas
lui-même armé ou que il se jette pas sur
vous et que vous et peut-être vous vous
seriez vous-même blessé bah oui mais si
mais c'est ça en fait
la question la question c'est descendu
la question c'est pas du tout ça la
question c'est de savoir si il est temps
la loi ou pas il ne l'est pas non c'est
bon il ne l'est pas mais sauf que le
gars ressort au bout de 2 jours voilà et
donc il se passe rien concrètement
le le truc essentiel c'est que ce
monsieur donc il est légitimement il
prend une arme de défense qui n'est pas
une arme pour tuer c'est-à-dire qu'il
peut vider toutes les balles en
caoutchouc qui est dedans il va jamais
tuer cet homme donc il ne va pas tenter
à sa vie c'est vrai que lui en fait il
risque plutôt la sienne si jamais le
voleur est armé mais dans l'autre cas de
figure ben c'est de dire veuillez
patienter monsieur j'appelle les
gendarmes et puis après le deuxième
volet c'est que deux heures deux jours
après il ressort les policiers savent
plus où il est et il peut continuer à
faire exactement ce qu'il veut si ça
c'est pas agent la grande question que
tout le monde se sur les réseaux c'est
pourquoi
on le relâche si doigts ne plus être sur
le territoire français
on ne sait pas d'où il vient en fait ça
le problème on peut accompagner on peut
sortir les jambes
l'assassin de Lola Dabia on sait dans
quel pays de quel pays elle vient donc
éventuellement on peut la renvoyer dans
son pays et lui on le garde pas ils sont
exprès de donner des nationalités
différentes
comme ça en fait on sait pas d'où il
vient donc j'étais en train de me donner
les conseils
gilbertez
pas votre action voilà je sais que je
suis minoritaire là dessus ils
comprennent pas votre action et il se
disent que voilà vous êtes le symbole du
laxisme en France est-ce que vous leur
répondez mais je réponds que je préfère
être cambriolé plutôt que de menacer
quelqu'un avec une arme oh
au moins j'ai le mérite d'être franc ah
ouais au moins j'ai le mérite d'être
Franco elle est tranquille
moi j'ai sincèrement pas les moyens de
me laisser cambrioler moi non plus je
travaille je travaille chez artisan je
pense que tout le monde sait ce que
c'est je travaille 70 heures par semaine
pour gagner ma croûte et
non je ne laisse pas rentrer une
personne qui glande rien de la journée
autre que quand merder les gens pour me
piquer mon travail pour me piquer les
motos des clients pour
pour faire peur à ma famille bien sûr et
c'est tout malheureusement
si je suis dans cette situation là c'est
qu'il y a quelque chose qui va pas avant
que je pense aujourd'hui Adrien c'est
imaginons voilà que c'est mal tourné
aussi et vous auriez pu avoir aussi
votre vie qui bascule mais dans l'autre
sens c'est-à-dire comme le monsieur qui
s'est vengé à Roanne c'est à dire que un
moment ça se passe mal vous lui tirez
dessus ou bien vous le savez il y a une
bagarre vous le voilà c'est c'est vous
le blessez exactement voilà et derrière
c'est vous qui êtes donc incarcéré et
peut-être jugé et vous il vous remettent
pas dehors mais c'est sûr
donc vous rendez compte je suis solvable
et vous n'avez pas quatre identités
différentes donc là évidemment vous
foutez dans la merde c'est incroyable
c'est lui là lui il blesse le gars le
gars porte peu porter plainte contre lui
c'est ce qui s'est passé à Roanne hein
et et vous vous retrouvez peut-être vous
incarcéré votre famille et elle vient
cauchemar parce que en
vous avez rien demandé vous êtes
tranquillement chez vous et votre vie
bascule et votre famille derrière cette
vie en affaire et tout ça pour et c'est
ça aussi
de faire des justices expéditives et
cetera ça c'est pas ça qu'on demande là
on reste bloqué effectivement le mec il
devait quitter le territoire mais c'est
même pas ça le problème parce que tu
aurais pu avoir ce cas de figure tu
aurais pu avoir ce cas de figure avec
quelqu'un qui est qui a des papiers
français qui est français qui ne dort
pas déjà oui mais d'accord mais le
problème c'est pourquoi ce mec au bout
de 48 heures il est dehors si c'était un
Français qu'il avait fait il doit aussi
au bout de 48 heures le problème c'est
que on laisse des gens rentrer chez nous
il y a nos enfants qui jouent dans le
jardin là il a eu alarme mais si tu as
une maison ou tu as pas l'alarme et
qu'il y a un membre qui joue et qui
l'emmène le mot mais qui égorge le monde
on est tous là en train de dire mais
comment ça se fait qu'il est rentré dans
la maison on rentre pas chez les gens
normalement quand tu arrives au
commissariat et que tu dis je suis
rentré chez les gens normalement le
commissariat doit te mettre une pelle
exemplaire on rentre pas chez les gens
voilà donc moi il a dit qu'il a raison
tu rentres pas chez les gens c'est très
dangereux
[Applaudissements]
est-ce que vous auriez est-ce que vous
refuriez la même chose pour protéger ma
famille non mais là la même scène est-ce
que vous regrettez quelque chose ou bien
vous dites NON je viens parce que
maintenant vous dites
juste que le fait que je sois passé sur
plateau là enfin changer un peu les
choses même si je crois encore au Père
Noël et en plus on arrive sur la période
mais c'est ça et très beau il t'embrasse
un peu poilu je t'offre un rodrien
ne fait pas pipi
sérieusement c'est vrai que moi voilà là
je me dis je me dis que c'est moi je
pense à toi je me dis là peut-être ta
vie elle aurait pu basculer mais dans le
mauvais lance parce que tu imagines tu
tires et là le gars les gars parce que
il porte plein de contre toi derrière
moi je vous dis c'est ce qui s'est passé
à Roanne c'est incroyable parce que
c'est le père qui a vengé sa fille qui a
retrouvé et il a porté plainte pourquoi
et blessures contre le père en réunion
c'est ça
mais c'est le monde de Gilles Verdez
c'est ton monde Gilles excuse-moi de te
dire ça je sais même si je t'aime
beaucoup dans la vie et tu peux me
répondre bien entendu j'étais je t'adore
mais c'est vrai que tu es dans ce monde
là qui fait qu'aujourd'hui on est dans
l'immobilisme et qu'aujourd'hui ben
voilà il se passe des choses comme ça et
pour peu qu'il se passe des choses comme
ça il faut que ça avance il faut que
comme on dit géraline il faut qu'on
puisse il faut que les la police et les
moyens pas les moyens voilà qu'ils aient
qui eux derrière ça suive moi combien de
fois je croise des policiers des trucs
qui me disent Thierry de toute façon ça
sert à rien je vais te dire on va là on
se déplace même plus pour les trucs
comme ça on va les arrêter la boîte de
jour 2 jours après vont être dehors
qu'est-ce qu'on va à chaque fois on va
prendre un risque de jour tu es gentil
et en plus
de problèmes mentaux ou d'addiction etc
bah là aussi justement
vous vous faites bien le dire parce que
ça aussi aux limites sont banalise parce
que la personne elle a des des problèmes
puisque vous avez vu ce qui s'est passé
aux urgences avec à l'hôpital
donc apparemment voilà donc il a été
admis en hôpital psychiatrique c'est
fait
là vous parlez du drame de Tonneins de
la petite euh
exactement voilà donc voilà ça c'est
exactement ce que vous dites et là on en
reparlera lundi ça me rend fou
ce que je voulais dire Cyril c'est que
si vous allez au bout de votre logique
vous dites à ce monsieur votre vie peut
basculer parce que vous auriez pu tirer
si la personne vous charge Cyril moi si
je veux au bout de votre logique c'est
ne prenons pas d'armes contre les
cambrioleurs comme ça il y aura pas de
risque de leur tirer dessus
voilà
je vous donne je vous donne mon point de
vue je vous donne elle est trop risqué
c'est trop risqué tu penses à la vie de
ta famille tes enfants
merci en tout cas j'aimerais bien savoir
ce qu'on pensait téléspectateurs tiens
ça très important pour moi bien sûr
bravo merci Adrien